[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar multiflex applications in flow
cytometry
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckman coulter to learn more
visit
beckmancoulter.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr alfonso blanco associate professor
and director of flow cytometry conway
institute of biomolecular and biomedical
research university college dublin
dr blanco you may now begin your
presentation
great thank you very much
bill um
as i said i'm alfonso blanco
and uh director of law here at eucd uh
in ireland and that's why some some
people know me as alfonso from ireland
but reality is that i'm not irish the
first thing i would say is this is a
disclaimer so any anything that i would
say from here um it's my responsibility
and this is my
view of cytometry and things that um we
consider as
one way of doing it but there are many
many other ways of doing things in flow
cytometry so as i said i am not from
ireland i'm from spain this is me a few
years ago i grew up a little bit
and
i born in seville so the south of spain
but uh really i'm from galicia all my
families um practically from from
galicia and that's where i did my degree
in biology and afterwards i was doing my
psd
and it was working with this instrument
here a cultural epics elite that was a
sales order and i was working with
plants
after the phd i decided to move in
ireland and i was the first one running
a core facility here in ireland for flow
and that was a few years ago back in
2004
and that was the first core facility of
los angeles here in ireland and
afterwards were quite a few other core
facilities um here
so um the normal thing
is growing up and expanding and this is
what what the facility looked like a few
years ago back in 2004 i have a couple
of analysis here and a cell shorter at
the end and
we were lucky to get quite a few
fundings and grants and we were
increasing the amount of instrumentation
that we have and also the variety
based on
the applications that were coming up the
growth of the technology the needs of
the users and what you can see in my old
lab is that we have practically
everything fully
full of instrumentation
and then we move to a larger lab where
you can see we have more space that was
in 2013
but the technology is moving and
advancing and several of the units that
we have on that image
has disappeared because they became
obsolete or because they were no use
anymore and we have to replace it with
with new instrumentation
um one of my main roles and this
probably one of the things i enjoy more
is in training and education like i'm
showing there we are now
running this summer school we we do lots
of winter and summer schools and this is
the last one we are doing the summer
school
that was on the 24th of june
what we do is a mix of lectures and
hands-on and
we in the last year we have done a
face-to-face together with with virtual
practical sessions
we have to re-adapt and grow and learn
from from experience that we have the
bad experience in this case with the
covets but it helps us to understand
more things so it's a combination of
lectures and hands-on so what we are
trying to look is for instrumentation
that is
easy for the the users to to understand
and follow up
that they are not scary
um as i said i'm involved not just in
trainings
at ucd we are
participating in several different
training courses and
and different workshops like this once
organized by the esca the european
society for clinical cytometry
here with ifcc we organize a couple of
courses in latin america and that's
where we are organizing many other
actions as well and the schools this one
here was the first isaac school
at
south america was in brazil in
rio de janeiro and sao paulo and i'm
also involved with excited and the
european distributor for excite and we
organize several courses in different
places
what is my main target as a core manager
my main target is basically introduce
as we are in academia we have to
introduce students into the flow
cytometry world and we have to train
them on the usage but most important is
to make sure that they understand the
concept rather than training let's say
we are educating them into cytometry
of course as part of the role of the
core facilities is helped with the setup
of each one of the samples and protocols
okay with the analysis and re-analysis
and before all of that we have to
explore
which ones are the options that they
have possibilities design of the panels
etc and in the day by day when the users
are running the samples we have to fix
some of the mechanical problems it
doesn't matter which one is your
instrument they will always have an
issue and we always have to fix it
uh of course we
one of the things we have to do is
before we buy the instrument we have to
make some research and look at which
ones are the offers that we have
available on the market what are the
pros and the crowns and every single
instrument they have the big benefits
and they have their
not so good benefits and so pros and
cons it's like buying a car when we're
buying a car we have our favorite one
also we look at the budget but at the
end of the day we have to look is if it
will be the perfect one for
my applications where i want to do what
i want to do
and
as i said because i i'm really involved
in education on cytology and this is one
of my passions i want to make flow
cytometry really attractive by making it
attractive and accessible to everyone
and what we are doing is trying to
attract more users into the facility and
this is
this is something that we really need uh
it's a core facility we have to charge
for the usage so more charges more users
more users more charges
then the administrator is happier
and
that's at the end of the day's small
business but definitely what we want to
do is make solve
solving problems and we want to make
sure that everyone has their samples
analyzed and their questions the
biological questions are properly
addressed and answered
so that's that's the philosophy of any
core facility and this is basically not
just you as a user that's me as well
as a core manager you're coming with
these the experiments that you want to
develop and sometimes we are absolutely
lost we we cannot be the experts of
everything we need to learn and the only
way of learning is by asking questions
and talking with with the other experts
and
just joining actions and joining
information to make sure that we are
moving forward
so imagine that this is you nowadays and
you you want uh to learn what's flow
cytometry and you want to know what you
have to do to answer the question that
your supervisor is telling you how you
do this and you need to use flow
cytometry and you arrive to the lab and
you see okay they have one equipment and
you see something like this full of
wires and
boxes and you don't know on lots of
screens
it's slightly scary especially when you
look at more details and you see all
those wires
started to be more and more scary and so
you see the lasers there
while lasers and fluidics and
electronics and all those screens and
especially when you see all these danger
signs around uh you started to regret to
be on the lab and especially when you
see all these biohazards all around the
lab definitely what you will do is
basically run away from the lab you
don't want to be there anymore
so uh what we are doing it's going to
meetings and events like this one's
organized by the international society
of for advancement of cytometry and it's
kind of going to the supermarket you
have different offers from different
technologies and different companies
and in 2008 there was one small tiny
tiny flow cytometer called equity from a
company that was completely new was
actually in this case and the instrument
was a c6
it was a very
different instrument because it was very
small very compact
there was no fluidics big tanks of
fluidics it was kind of weird to see
that kind of flow cytometer and they
were promising that was a flow cytometer
and also they have another staff on the
electronics that was quite different
and was the way that the photo
multipliers were located
they have seven log decades so all of
that was kind of weird
but at the end of the day it was a very
easy to use flow cytometer
as you can see any users were able to
run their samples this is one of the
uses that we have in the facility at the
time as you can see he's a little bit
upset
or he looks a little bit upset but
that's because i told him he has to wear
lab coats and gloves and he was not
quite happy with that but anyway he was
running happily this instrument and
getting the data which is at the end of
the day what they wanted to do
as i said it was kind of sl slightly
different and one of the big difference
is that they were using peristaltic
pumps
to to move the samples and and this is
the filter that we have here and these
are the tubing moving everything into
the flow cell we have here two lasers
the blue laser red laser they were both
collinear four was cut in the front side
scattered in a right angle and then the
photomultipliers were aligned in
different angles than the right scatter
so it was kind of strange but it was
doing the job
and the other thing that was weird is to
see that they have only one filter in
front of the photomultipliers where
usually we are looking at multiple
filters aligned one with the other
that was kind of um different as well
and as i said this this log and evening
scale was great because practically
everything was fitting nevertheless not
all the samples were properly set up or
fitted into that logarithmic scale this
here this is a gfp it's a very bright
transfection that we have and as you can
see the problem that we have is that it
goes completely off the scale it was too
bright so there were two options we can
buy a neutral density filter or we can
use the filter
on the next detector on the fl2 which
was a for 585.40 which is better for pe
not for a feed c
but anyway we could get the full
distribution
of the of the detect of this signal okay
so there were a lot of things that i
really enjoy with this machine many many
many things and i really fall in love as
soon as i see this instrument the
accuracy six the later on has been
bought by pectin dickinson
but at the same time there were things
that i didn't like
i didn't like to lose one of the
channels because my signal was too
bright and i have to use it on that one
i like to readjust
that situation or the fact that we only
have four detectors even if we have uh
the blue and red with the flexible
configuration i like to have more lasers
and more colors and the reason is
because the users were demanding
more options
so usually love and hate they are
divided by very thin line
so even if i love it there were things i
hated when i have to face the instrument
because it was so easy to use
but at the same time
didn't have the complexity that i needed
in a core facility
a few years later in 2014 there was one
instrument called cytogene was kind of
different than the others but was based
on the equity platform in this case the
instrument has three lasers and you can
analyze far more colors with 12 colors
which you can analyze at the same time
and that was presented inside of the
isaac meeting in 2014
in 2013 sorry and in 2014 show up as
site of lex and that's because bergman
culture acquired a cytogene company
so in 2014 they showed the cytogene that
was shown in 2013 as the new cytoflex
platform
and one of the biggest advantages rather
than using photomultipliers they're
using a new generation which is the
avalanche photodiode system so apds
which are here these are as you can see
very small and they were located in the
back of all these
mirrors that we have here
the light was redirected using this
fiber optic and one of the biggest
advantages and that's why they use it
is as you can see on this paper
published in 2008 and one of the authors
is paul wallins
you can see that the advantage of the
avalanche photodiodes works with the
photo multiplier
is that these ones are able to get far
better signal more resolution on the
signal that you get into each one of
them
more
more quantum efficiency means that since
things that they are dimmer becomes more
a bit more brighter
and that's a big
change
we can sadly detect signals that they
are quite demon expression with
no problem okay and the other thing that
we can see on this graph is that these
are especially nice and very sensitive
on the wavelengths on the red that makes
a big difference on the red emission
when we are looking at apds
versus photomultipliers
the other thing that has an advantage on
these instrument cytogenes cytoflex
nowadays versus the vdd aquery is the
possibility of tunable dynamics that
means that
basically we want to get this one like
this
in the proper filter
so we could modify in this case not the
voltage what we have is a modification
of the gains
but at the end of the day it's
practically the same
and
how this work
so this is how i see it imagine that you
are taking this picture okay
this is what you will have with a
conventional flow cytometer
but if you increase
this dynamic range you can see that the
picture is nicer we can see more things
in this space and look at this cathedral
this is in san pedro's work you can see
the cathedral there but looks like it's
off the screen we would like to have
that one in the center of the screen so
this dynamic range
with the possibility of being
fine-tuning what the laws mean is
basically to drop down the gains and put
that signal exactly where we want it
so as i said similar to the normal
voltage this is my signal fluorescence
intensity from the propane your light
very bright signal as you can see it
goes completely off the scale on this
other detector it's on the scale but if
i want to place both of them in the same
place the only thing i have to do is
decrease the gains that we are applying
to the channel
and that's what we do
similar as i said to how the
photomultiplier works with
photomultipliers you're changing the
voltage with these uh avalanche photo
diodes what you're changing is the gain
as i said there was a change here we
have now the cytoflex and they have
moved from cytoflex cytoflex s cytoflex
lx
this site of lex s has instead of the
three lasers that we have originally
with the cytoflex has four lasers and
the cytoflex lx has the possibility of
getting up to 26 lasers with 21 colors
which means that we have a huge amount
of flexibility
and now in the last in the last year
beckman culture has released also
something to complement
this equipment not just the possibility
of looking at my cells with high
sensitivity they allow us as well to
sort those cells and this is a new
member of the family which is the
cytoflex srt the new shorter using the
same the same technology than the site
of lex s with a very similar with the
same configuration than the site of lex
s which makes a perfect complement to a
core facility where you have the
cytoflexes to analyze your data and then
the the users can move straight into the
cytoflex srt and sort that population so
as you can see
with that combination i'll be quite
happy
in this case this combination of
cytoflex s and cytoflex srt
was during one of the training courses
we have done we were able to do a
training of people analyzing and sorting
at the same time
so this is this is the user as i said um
that's quite upset because has some
limitations but now we put that big
smiley face
not just because he's wearing the lab
coat and i'm not upset anymore is
because you can see
you have far more capabilities now to
analyze your samples uh flexibility in
terms of the excitation sources
flexibility as well in terms of the
capabilities that you have for selecting
the floor the the wavelength that you
want it also has a 96 well play loader
here and a very nice and easy stable
fluidics platform
so
this is my instrument and now
what is the next step
so the first thing i will do is check
how sensitive is the instrument which
ones are the capabilities and for that
usually we use beads in this case this
was one of the first things i tested
checked the ap bits and the capabilities
and as you can see in all the different
channels we can see how sensitive the
instrument is this is fit c per cp and
if you look at prcp and the other system
you can see that the low end practically
doesn't have any resolution even with
the ap beats we have the green laser but
also look at the capabilities on the apc
750
we can nicely resolve those populations
with the violet
same situation you can resolve nicely
ea peaks
from 450 525
wireless extend
the low and it started to be a bit
weaker okay but
the resolution that you have on the
upper upper side is magnificent
so very sensitive instrument very
powerful
for what we want to do which is
basically working with cells
but usually people is thinking of flow
cytometry immunology big cells mammalian
cells and a whole blood but we also want
to work with platelets with bacteria
with viruses cream but we are in a core
facility so we have to be open to work
with a huge variety of samples we have
to work with cells that are coming from
tissue we have people here working with
retinas we have people working in the
sperm we have working uh we have groups
working in agriculture in botany so that
means we are have to work with plants we
have to work with
people working with algae with fetal
plaque
we are working a lot with groups here
working with nanotechnology
and nowadays we also have people working
with with the evs and viruses
so therefore sensitivity is definitely
one of the issues one of the main issues
so we need to optimize our instruments
it's not just as the instrument comes by
default we need to do something similar
to where we do with the conventional
photocytometers that they have
photomultipliers that you do that you do
the vulturation we do the optimization
by gain tradition okay we optimize the
gains
this is a really nice video uh provided
by um one of the beckman culture
engineers hi kim
and you can see we have here different
tubes loaded with
these gains at different settings from
10 to 100 at different positions and
what we will see is those eight big bits
and see how sensitive the instrument is
at the different positions so what we'll
do is we'll put different channels and
we'll keep one stable in this case it's
fixing so we have one two three four
five peaks and then the last
peaks here they're all together
in this case in this channel we have one
and two that are quite broad and look at
all of these ones together in this other
one so what i will do is i will play
play and this this will be animation of
how they are changing when we are
increasing the gains and what you will
see is that these peaks as soon as we
started to increase the gains they
started to separate okay you will see
them in these ones at different points
on the gain so there we go you can see
how they are increasing now look at this
one they're becoming very
very very sharp
these ones are coming smaller and one of
the things will you will find out is
that this peak here suddenly arrived to
the maximum position it saturated the
detector and this next one will join so
that means that we are losing
that capability of resolving very bright
population so keep going let's go play
and you can see this one suddenly is
saturated this one is saturated now
we're expanding on the low end we can
see more separation but suddenly
starting to increase
higher the gain as well what we'll get
is as well a multiplication on the
background and the populations on the
low end are now quite well resolved
so what we need to do is try to arrive
to compromise
these are the different detectors and
these are the different samples that we
analyze at those different gains and
what we can see is that there are some
positions here that the detectors are
fully saturated
uh on the other side we can see
some of the detectors they do not
saturate
uh we can see as well that some of the
detectors they get a huge amount of
background some others they are not
affected
what we are looking at we are looking
for gains that don't saturate the
detector but also that we have not
increased on the on the gains what we
are looking is for those gains that are
right in the middle those ones that are
giving us the maximum distance between
your negative populations your dims and
your brides
for that rather than using the eyes we
can look at the statistics and we'll try
to identify them by using staining index
signal to noise
robust coefficient of variation and
we'll try to identify which one is the
position
for that gain
a gain that is giving us confidence that
will get a good good signal
and we will do it for each one of the
channels that we have on the instrument
that way we'll get a minimum a position
for starting and that we have the
confidence that it's quite close to what
we want to use
for most of our samples
right so we have an instrument that is
quite sensitive what we can do as i said
we are in a course facility so the
applications it could be anything that
you can imagine anything any
applications that you have in mind it's
coming through the door and we have to
face them and the nice thing is
for most of these applications we always
have a solution with the cytoflex
platform
and remember not just for the analysis
we can also start to sort with these
instruments so we have the cytoflex srt
so the first thing we will consider is
what about the
autofluorescence
are your cells out of fluorescence what
is the minimum autofluorescence remember
that all of you are out of fluorescence
what is the autoresistance we put a
source of light and suddenly your
characteristics on your cells are
transferring changing the wavelength
producing a different different
wavelength so in this case we are
collecting these white light and we
transfer this into a red light
older you are more out of fluorescence
you will
and there are many things affecting this
autofluorescence for instance the size
not just the size also the composition
the content of these cells how many
vesicles you have that will change
as well that out of fluorescence level
and these are things that we need to
consider when we are doing any kind of
analysis for instance
here we have one sample where we have
the cells that we expose to
nanoparticles these nanoparticles are
uptake
and that produced a small change in my
forward scatter
as you can see there is a small increase
from
sample control to the sample treated
changes in auto fluorescence will be
also reflected on my side scatter this
one is looks like far more complex than
this one so one of the things we cannot
forget is that this changes on
this formation of my cells will affect
as well my side scatter side scatter is
a good way of looking at physiological
morphological changes on myself and you
can see there it's clearly
showing up that increase on my side
scatter when we have
these events inside my cells
as i said autofluorescence is there
especially
nice to consider when we are working
with plants and sometimes is a really
dramatic change and this is a problem
when we are trying to put some markers
like for instance if we are trying to
use propane unit light to label the dna
content of these plants and we want to
work with those plants and know how much
dna they have the problem if we use
propylene geolite is that we'll be
overlapping on the mission with the
chlorophyll
so we need to consider that
uh but not just the chlorophyll if you
think on these cells they have many
other things they have cell walls so
they will have lignins they will have
they will have
tonight they will have
polyethylenediates they will have a lot
of different
things
in their composition that will affect
the emission of that
outer fluorescence so these are things
that we need we need to consider
and this is a clear example these are
the plants i was doing my psd with these
are ferns and when we look at the
structures that we have on the back
which is basically the spores and the
organelles are produced in the spores
the sporangia we can see that depending
on the wavelength that we are using to
excite and collect the signal we can see
for instance the spores here they're
practically no product not producing any
kind of emission meanwhile these rings
here that we have these cells of the
ring
they are producing a huge amount of
fluorescence in this wavelength but if
we change wavelengths and we move into
this other one the spores are the ones
that are producing the highest amount of
autofluorescence and the ring
the cells of the ring practically no
fluorescent
so
depending on the structure depending on
the cells that you're using they could
be more or less fluorescent and this is
something that you need to consider when
you're working with your your sample so
this is for instance one one example of
one of the plants we make a chopping we
analyze them and we can see exactly that
effect we have some of these channels
massively affected with those out of
fluorescence
and other channels that they have
practically no out of fluorescence like
these ones
so if i have to select a marker to
distinguish or differentiate anything
those will be the ones i will use
because i will be easier to recognize a
big change rather than these ones that
they are practically saturated because
of that autofluorescence
is that a problem no usually it's an
advantage and this is something that we
we have to start to learn use the
autofluorescence as an advantage in this
case my my users are trying to compare
um the production of a protein
that is
when we have these two cell lines here
and as you can see
both of them they have similar uh
forward and side scatter so if we put
them both of them uh growing at the same
time using forward scatter and say the
scatter will make quite different
uh we can use side scatter versus pe
here okay you can see side scatter is
practically the same piece
signal that we have there is very
similar so what we have in this case the
production of the protein that we are
interested in
is
this one here okay
and what about the other expression is
here
what we cannot differentiate is
the production of this one and the
production of the second cell line when
they are coexisting when we put them
both to grow at the same time
so rather than using side scatter what
if we use another detectors we have
remember we have a lot of different uh
channels there so we can use them to
characterize the autofluorescence so you
can see uh in this case feed c
channel is higher on this cell line
than this other cell line
and when we run them both together
difficult to differentiate which one is
a protein introduced by one cell line
which one is production from the second
cell line if we change now to apc now
the other cell line is brighter
on that channel the autofluorescence is
higher
but if we look at pacific blue on coming
from the violet laser pacific blue
channel the 450 we can see how different
those two cell lines are in their
minimum out of resin
when we analyze the production of one
doesn't overlap
with the second one and when we look at
the production of the protein
we can see that that's an overlap with
the other
even more what we can see is that when
they are producing the protein
the level of autofluorescence of this
cell line drops down
and this hasn't been seen
if we haven't played with these levels
of autofluorescence
so look at other channels not like just
to put colors also to understand how is
your cell working
this is another example where we are
looking at
some particular detection of receptors
on the surface of my cells and you can
see the blue line is my control and you
can see that the blue line is giving me
two peaks the autofluorescence is not
equal your cells are growing your cells
are expanding your cells are
proliferating your cells are doing
things so the autofluorescent level will
not be the same it's heterogeneous
anyway we have the marker and we can see
we can see a clear increase on my
detector using this laser and this
bypass
what if you use
a different laser exactly the same
bypass it's an optimal laser and this is
the advantage of having at the
site of legs we can select different
wavelengths for excitation and we can
use the same
bandpass filters and you can see by
using the optimal excitation source we
can get a better resolution on my sample
if we try with the different filters we
can see we can resolve as well the steam
medium or bright signalings
but if we use the perfect combination of
lasers and
detectors or filters we can clearly
distinguish a very positive signal
and this is what i like on these
instruments is the flexibility to choose
excitation sources and emission
and play with these ones to try to
optimize and maximize the information we
get from every single sample that you
have
in this case we we are trying to work
with samples that they are trying to do
an uptake and the group in this case is
from professor kenneth dawson they
wanted to
look at the receptors that we have and
see if there is any relationship between
the receptors and the nanoparticle
uptake
so we have here nanoparticle uptake and
the marker to detect that receptor
and you can see as i showed you before
we have the negative and then we have
the three different levels of emission
and now we put the nanoparticles this is
my control without the marker for the
receptor what if we put the
nanoparticles and the receptor we can
see
that they're exactly in the right place
where we expected to see so resolution
in this instrument on the cytoflex is
fantastic
let's go and talk now
about viability because it's definitely
something that we need to consider even
if you're not measuring a live cells and
dead cells we need to look at viability
as a marker to remove that cell from our
analysis
excuse me right
usually if we are working with cells in
culture um what we will do to look at
cells um we just select forward inside
the scatter we can see here the junk and
we put the polygon to try to remove the
junk
and we can see here that we are trying
to do the singlet so we will use
followers category area forward scatter
height here we can see my cells and here
the activates so we'll put that singlet
gate there right
now this is the same but now we have my
samples treated and they're dying so we
can see here my dead cells let's put the
gates exactly in the same places
but it's better this one
or this one
there's people that prefer this one
there are others that prefer to use this
rectangle
english we'll select that one
and now
now it's more difficult to select where
is the junk and where is my death
population we cannot see the clear
distinction between them and same here
we're looking for singlets what is this
population that is pulling out here i
have no clue
let's change the scale from linear scale
to logarithmic scale and in the site of
legs you can change as as long as you
want in other instruments you have to
click
and say i want to record this in linear
or i want to record this in log the
cytoflex has the possibility to select
both at the same time and transfer them
from one to the other and i personally
prefer to work in logarithmic scale
compress the data and we have a better
view of what's going on even with
sourcing culture
when we look at these ones we can nicely
see my alive cells here my dead cells
here and the junk and i can clearly
distinguish where the junk is
even when we're looking at forward
scatter area height i can see my single
is here the aggregates here and what we
have here is my dead cells and this
straight line that is going kind of a
diagonal are my chunk
so this is the way i will select if i
want to do forward and side scatter and
this is the way i will look at them over
here you can see i'm selecting cells
and i'm removing the junk which remains
in red in black sorry
if we do the other way around and we
select the singlets by selecting my test
population and my single cells and
excluding the aggregates and the junk
and i go back to the sample this is how
it looked like
that gating here that we use here looks
like it's practically collecting every
single event that we have in our life
and death and that's what i really like
to start with in my analysis
let's have a look at how this could
change from lineal to logarithmic when
we are having samples that they are
happy and alive or death you can see my
life cells are here my life cells here
we don't have the group of dead cells as
we mentioned before there how these ones
are slightly to be damaged and changing
the position we have more dead cells
here and the aggregates on this
direction
there we go now we put the gates and we
can see
cells that are alive
slightly damage
and death
we can see here more dead cells but they
are already moving into the junk so
they're moving from here
to there
and these are completely junk
fragments already so if this is the junk
as we can see there
these other ones
that are now in black at the remaining
as you can see this is where we have
ourselves
so that's why i like to use that kind of
gating
to look at my uh cells if i'm trying to
analyze alive and death that's the way i
would select them or just basically
remove my dead cells from the analysis
when we are looking at samples we have
to be careful with the sample
preparation we have to be gentle and
counted cells and we usually have as
well counting cell speeds
here so we have acute three minutes five
minutes or ten minutes and here we can
see
more or less we have more cells here but
more or less is not good we need within
numbers we will compare this sample
present preparation with triple express
at 3 minutes 5 minutes or 10 minutes we
can see that looks like triple express
is better but as i said looks like
doesn't mean it is we need to look at
the numbers we need to look at
percentage 12 percent 25 46 clearly this
one has more
20 52 43 so looks like this one has
higher percentage
so
we compare those ones look like triple
express has percentage wise more but
doesn't mean that we'll have more sales
percentage could be slightly different
we have to look as well as at events per
microliter and this is advantage as well
on the site of legs it allows us to
measure the true volumetric counting so
we can look at the number of events that
we have per microliter and definitely in
this case we have 534
versus the 422 so we have more cells per
microliter than we when we use acutase
for 10 minutes
so this one is an example where we have
used this method as well to optimize how
we get more cells
in this case trying to optimize
this system which
is in this case for collides
using a new device because when we are
using the traditional methods the
problem is if we extended too much the
digestion to get the samples that we
want we have a lack of viability as you
can see here using traditional methods
only
not even 30 of our cells
are alive and the other problem is when
we are using traditional methods like
chopping
the chopping is not equal it's not
homogeneous
one day we are chopping more some other
days we are chopping less depending as
well on the blade
and that's when we were partnering in
this case with syntec to try to evaluate
how is the medi-machine to
working in terms of homogenizing the
system to get
always a repetitive way of collecting my
cells that there is no variation because
i'm in better mood or bad mood so we
evaluated the machine and different
medical systems
for this kind of tissue this is a i work
with the [ __ ] and we'll announce
from
my university
and as you can see this is a clear
improvement with more than 84 percent of
the cells alive and the best thing is
quite consistent it's quite reproducible
over time
also we could see that there is no
damage on the expression markers we have
tried in this case with different kind
of of cells
and we have seen as well with this one
so you can see it's uh the centric lymph
nodes previous patches and spleen that
the viability is always above 80
so definitely working with this system
help us a lot on these analysis
we can get more cells and in better
shape
and the advantage is not just percentage
is higher it's also the number of cells
that we collect back is much higher than
before
so higher number of cells
number of cells viable and the most
important thing higher consistency
when we are looking at cell cycle which
is another a key application especially
in the islam
and this is funny because every time i
was looking at these waves on the covet
i was looking at them as cell cycle this
professional deformation i think
one of the key things here is these
detectors we want to resolve those
populations we want to resolve cells in
g1 s phase g2m so getting systems like
this one with that sensitivity will help
us a lot and i was really impressed with
the sensitivity of the cytoflex because
usually propane is right we'll use it
with the blue or the yellow green laser
and the 585 610
filter
but
this
fluorescent it's going not so far really
far away it goes from pe detector or ecd
detector on the yellow green psi five
you can see perfect cell cycle or the
blue laser we don't have a good soft
cycle on fizzy but we have it really
good on per cv
we have it as well on the red laser with
apc and abc750
and the violin laser we have it on the
red channels
it's like whoa hold on a second yellow
and blue
violet i couldn't understand it but red
let's see how is the excitation emission
if you see here we have 561
we can excite pi optimally 488 we get
signal
violet not so much but we have a lot of
copies and if we consider red
the red is not having the stock shift
well we are getting only this proportion
here
this is very low but as i said with the
apd's and the content efficiency we have
a lot of copies to even have a perfect
cell cycle and again we can combine just
cell cycle with other characteristics
changes like in the morphology to
characterize if my cells are
growing and making it larger or not
the other thing is we can look is uh for
bdsa similar to elisa
we will have the reports and for that we
have usually a luminex platform here
which is kind of automated to look at
micrograms per ml
as i said before
we have these kits and we can analyze
them fantastic but sometimes we have
warnings about the number of events that
we are collecting and when these
instruments are producing this
information usually the company will say
look it's your problem uh you haven't
mixed up myself properly et cetera we
get the statistics and we look at number
events we have in each one of the wells
analyzed
what we have done is analyze the same
plates parallel the instrument the
luminex versus my cytoflex we can get
exactly the same positions that we have
on the luminex with really good
separation of resolution and we also
have the possibility to look at the
number of events per microliter not so
not just the number of events that we
have counted also the concentration per
microliter and we can see in our kits
was quite inconsistent in terms of the
numbers and it was not just one plate it
was in several plates and with this
information we could come back to the to
the company
if we think now a little bit smaller and
we go to microbiology we have g's and
bacteria et cetera et cetera there are
several groups that are trying to do
that for instance people that's working
in genomics
and they use yeast as one of the um
as one of the models the light modules
to work with in this case they're
working with
g's that they transfect with gfp and
tomato or in cherry and we can see the
big differences between one and the
others the only way you can see
populations in the middle with different
levels of this transaction what they
want to do they want to sort these
populations and not want several ones so
it means i have to be here for many many
hours working with them side by side
nevertheless the new srt
is so simple to use it's as complex as
the faxaria but it's so simple to use
that the instrument can be used by the
user and they can spend as much time as
they want during the weekends or during
night time
the other thing that we mentioned before
is that you have the 90s well play
loader and the idea is to work with
plates
and we have all these bacterias
analyzing in this case this is my
scatter we can see if my cells are alive
or death and look at the receptor and
see in my bacteria they have the
receptor as you can see it's very
important to look at viability because
look like they have the receptor but
these ones are dead
it's better this position where they
have the receptor and most of my cells
are alive
they have a really good
softwares to show you not just if you
have them or not analyzed but also to
look at the levels of viability or the
receptor expression
so really nice software not just for the
acquisition but also for the re-analysis
and these are different bacteria that
different users wants to use in this
case they are producing
some proteins that the as you can see
they crystallize in red
so four was kind of side scatter we have
the protein here of expression but when
we have fee addition you can see we have
more red
and what's happening is look like we
have an increase on my side scatter
remember if we look at side scatter
this is correlated to these crystals but
also look at the fluorescence clearly
has increased the fluorescence level
fantastic let's go to the brightest one
because they will be the ones they have
more protein expressed so protein
expression height size scatter high this
is my target then
this is the one we want to sort so what
we will do is we look at this one again
this is my cyto9 with these are my
bacteria cyto9 and we have a viability
marker in this case drug 7
when we have the protein expression and
on this one we will look
that side scatter
here is slightly different
when we look at track 7
we can see that there are a lot of dead
cells here
and what is happening here
it increases here because of the drug 7
overlapping but at the same time we can
see most of them are death when we look
only at the live cells
the level of expression it's very low
but now we have this group here that we
know that they're bacteria that they are
alive and they have the protein of my
injuries those are the ones that we want
to sort
not the other ones
okay
how we sort we can sort in our plates
which is really nice
we can see here
the volume for a second
play it again
so you can see
that in every single movement we are
putting one single bacteria and
afterwards
we just grow them
okay so here we can see that each one of
those colonies are coming from my
bacterias except the first one this
middle one that we have 10 bacteria and
that's why the colony is slightly bigger
we have done exactly the same thing with
the srt in collaboration with a group in
poland called sam probie
with joanna and kasia and the help of
mihai mihao miao
and we were preparing the samples and
selecting again those bacteria we want
to check we want to check if these are
my bacteria alive this one's our death
and these ones we don't know if they're
alive or death
so we just selected them and we place
them into another plate
and we sort them and you can see these
are my alive and these ones here should
are the population that we have here
they haven't grown in that agar but they
have tried different buffers and
different medias and in different
conditions they were able to get those
cells that do look like damage because
they are in between one and the other
but in reality they could recover them
and they were alive
we can select if we have multiple
different kinds of bacteria we can
select them put them in different
colonies and later on
do a pcr to know which one is which
identify the different subpopulations
let's go now for
mve characterization very small particle
detection
um for that we we need
a very sensitive instrument uh why the
mvs micro vesicles extracellular
vesicles exosome they are all found in
different body fluidics they can be
found in just into spatial space and
usually they are coming with the antigen
content from the cells that they are
coming from
they usually have membrane bounds with
vesicles that they contain micro
phospholipids and a few years ago they
were considered as cellular degrees and
that's why we didn't pay attention they
were the junk
that we we excluded in our analysis
but what we have found with people is
finding is that
those ones those vesicles are concerning
mrna and proteins that they can be
transferred and transported between
different cells in different parts of
the body
some of the others they can be used to
remove misfolding proteins cytotoxic
agents metabolic waste so when when i
was talking with people and they were
explaining me this that they could have
different sizes different compositions
the content inside was there and they
want to classify and characterize
uh what came to my mouth
my mind is basically this garbage
we have different kind of garbage with
different kind of containers that they
could have different things inside and
as uh or famous however shapiro used to
say garbage in carriage out
so
why do you want to do this oh we want to
classify them okay
how do you classify them if we think on
the kind of garbage that we have
we can think on this kind of bags but we
have these other kind of bags so the
characteristic and where it's coming
from is clearly different and what it
contains is different we look at this
back is clearly different and again
cargo and content could be quite
different but they will help us to
characterize what is what and what they
contain and this is what the
users want to do characterize these
different bags
but when we look at each one of them we
can see the refraction index is
different
based on two things what they have
outside and what they have inside the
characteristics
of the package and the content
and they wanted to do it by flow
cytometry but flow cytometry is designed
for
cells mammalian cells so this is stolen
from edwin valley poor presentation
and i really like it this is how a cell
would look like in a flow cytometer
and this is how an eevee an
extracellular vesicle will look like in
the flow cytometer by a small so what we
need is a very precise instrument to
analyze
so
what it has been found is that the
ultraviolet side at the violet side
scatter is more precise for very small
particles and the cytoflex lx has that
option to detect nanoparticle resolution
so this is a
technical node from beckman culture you
can see here violet side scatter is an
optical optional configuration for
nanoparticle resolution to be able to
separate clearly the noise from the
different kinds of in this case sizing
beads
these are the dragon green beads
analyzed on the side of legs by john
ticks and bacillus
so what you do
basically on the instrument is coming
with this
violet
filter here in a detector based block
and what you need to do is just
basically change those two filters from
the position so you remove the 405 and
you place it into 450 just by pulling it
out and plugging the other one in
and you have this one what if you have
to combine them with different markers
what is this there are lots of people
working in eb that they want to use the
brilliant violet 421 which will be
analyzed in this one so what we'll do is
move this filter to 450 to the next one
we'll place a 405 here and this 525 will
occupy that position
is this new no it is not new we have
this violet configuration or the usage
of violet side scatter in instruments
like the atun nxt
and they use it in this case to
recognize the retrocytes and exclude
erythrocytes from platelets and
leukocytes in the no wash no lyse system
so you can see here the retrocytes and
you can see here the platelets and
leukocytes these ones they have a
different
way
of scattering the light more into the
blue laser than on the 405 laser side
scatter
the other thing before
i move on into how we use it on the ev
analysis the other thing we need to
consider when we are working with tvs is
that this one
could be coming with many others and
when we are looking
at this big amount of evs that would be
looking like a summary
of all of them together
so that means the signal will be much
larger and the signal will be much
brighter than when we are looking at
each one independently
and this is what is called the swarming
effect
what we need to do when we are working
with evs very small particles is make a
a series of dilutions to make sure that
we are working with one single event at
a time
and there are two things on the side of
lexis telling us be careful with that
the first thing is increase
on these scatter values on the median
fluorescence intensity and the second
thing that we can see is the number of
aborts is quite quite
high
when we are doing dilutions or a series
of dilutions we can see the median drops
down the
groups are much tighter and the number
of awards decrease
much really really dramatically so now
we can know that we are working with
beads
versus this one which is a swarming
effect
the other thing if we want to make sure
that we are working with single events
even if we have a very low number of
events it's trying to remove the
aggregates again area versus height we
use in this case the violet side scatter
it's quite difficult to see where is the
border between aggregates and singlets
what i found is by using the height
versus the width here we can nicely
separate my single events versus the
aggregates
i will use this one and now i apply this
gate here and you can see how tight
is my resolution which is far better
than this gate in here so i prefer to
use
violet
side scatter high violet side scatter
width
to differentiate my single population
from my aggregated particles
and the other thing i want to point out
is that apart from the violet side
scatter here we have another scatter
here which is a coming from the red side
scatter so what we can use is this red
side scatter and transfer into any of
these
detectors here
and then we'll get the red side scatter
red side scatter what's that f4
it's an advantage or disadvantage
you will find out now and i find that
it's a very good and advantage position
so these are
the mega mix that everyone is using or
some groups are using to try to set up
the instruments for evs fitzy versus
side scatter blue with localized mic
beats here is forward scatter no good
resolution for a small particle
detection and this is how my particles
look like my evs will look like with
that particular setting when we look at
blue versus red you can see it's
following this diagonal
and now we have the particles here
so it's a big advantage to have this one
so these are nice series of beads that
they have different sizes 80 100 150 and
300
and using this case the violet side
scatter this is forward scatter
blue side scatter you can see only able
to resolve the two larger populations
this is the violet we can resolve the
four populations and this is the red
in this case the red is able to resolve
the two top populations but with more
sensitivity than the blue
this is how it looks using now the the
rosetta beads from exometry you can see
blue versus red
and we can see the three different side
scatters and they are really good for
resolving these beads but if you look at
red versus violet the red has better
resolution than the violet side scatter
on the low end but it's better on the
higher end
compared to the red on the violet
when we look at rosetta beads
this is how it looks on the three
different combinations of blue violet
blue red red violet and you can see that
they are following more or less
more red than violet
when we look at the sci mega mix again
we can see that they are more red than
violet and when we look at the nist we
can see that in this case the nist is
more violet
than blue
so the combination of these three
different scatters will help us to
understand and find out those different
sub populations in a better way that if
we use them individualized
when we look at the apogees which are
different set of beads and some of them
they are green labeling
we can see the advantage of working with
the red and violet red and blue is that
we can differentiate that they are kind
of two different diagonals
when we look at this one here it goes to
the top side on the blue versus red
those are beads that they do not have
the green color
and when we look at the top side
you can see here there are more red than
blue or more violet than blue those are
these that they have the coloring on the
green
it makes sense because as soon as we
have these marbles and we color them
this the refraction index change and
because the refraction in the exchange
this relationship of the different
scatters on different wavelengths can be
affected as well
when we look at these nano in different
kind of analysis in this case there are
narrow particles and
we look at the blue versus violet it
looks like clearly violet is more
sensitive to resolve them when we look
at the blue versus the red it's
basically the same it's more red than
violet when we look at the red versus
violet they follow the diagonal and this
is helping me to differentiate the
nanoparticles
from the noise
interesting enough is that when we have
the red side scattering we put these
nanoparticles with protein corona the
protein corona is giving us a drop down
on the side scatter again similar effect
we have seen
before with these
narrow particles that they have the
fitzy color around
them so i was thinking uh probably it's
me probably it's my system so i talked
to my colleague and friend john ticks
and he said look can you repeat this
essay with your instrument so we we have
the same beats this is how they look
like on
my instruments in dublin and this is how
they look in boston as you can see the
same patterns are happening
now we combine the nist and the apogee
and we want to see if we are having a
diagonal or the same relationship
between the different beats or they are
randomly placed unlocated as you can see
depending on the composition or
depending on the structures you can see
that they're not following that i don't
know they're jumping up and down in
these diagonals
so keep talking about these these
particles we were working with uh
a group of researchers that they wanted
to compare two different um
insecticides that they are coming into
these kind of balls introduce into them
these balls are attached to the to the
skin of the of the insects and then they
release the poison
but the size is really variable
extremely variable
and the problem is that they break down
and they release the poison before they
arrive to the animal so the
effectiveness of the treatment drops
down so they wanted to characterize the
quality of these compounds
if you use microscopy it's very
difficult to characterize them even
electron microscopy we will not be able
to do it so we decided to go for flow
cytometry so this is how they look and
we use again violet side scatter
blue side scatter and red side scatter
as you can see the profiles for each one
of these beads is clearly different
not so much when we look at the
fluorescence except in a couple of
channels where we can see slightly
different so we combine this with ratios
and we can characterize the ratios and
the different scatters and we can see
the big difference on the patterns
between fresh in this case karate and
dry
karate or fresh lambda which is the
other one this is lambda
lambda fresh and lambda dry so to
characterize them we put the statistics
in the middle and we can see the
differences between fresh and dry
and the difference between each one of
those ones and we can characterize the
different
different insecticides
if we are looking at these are my mega
mix and now we want to look at evs if
it's coming from cells in culture we can
see here that the combination of violet
versus red is providing us far more
resolution to resolve in this case one
to three populations versus just one
if we use blue and violet
this is sample
one and it's able to resolve one two
three four
versus one again
on violet versus blue
here we can see two here we can see one
and two but also we can see this tail
here
this tail is coming
in some cases not in all the cases this
tail is coming when we have the most of
the events coming from this side you can
see here too
we have the top and the bottom
especially we have the bottom we can see
this tail coming from that one
okay
so again this violet red combination is
allowing me to characterize things that
with just the combination
of the violet and the blue we will not
be able to differentiate
what about the evs coming from
samples from plasma
evs for instance so we have an xm5 and
cd markers and the combination with red
and violet also will help us to
characterize them so look at this one
this is samples from the same patient on
day one and day three we have this
population here that doesn't appear on
day three and this one that shows up on
day three and is not coming in day one
when we're looking at these great events
that's fine but when we're looking at
this day one and two we can see two
populations with two different levels of
cd expression there is nothing in the
middle between those two when we look at
this population here we can see that
there's only one group of events
and interesting enough they have
intermediate
expression between those two look at
those two and the next one is in the
middle
this one one and two bright and dim and
this one is intermediate in both of them
so it means that there could be
different levels of expression if we
increase in this case
uh the size of my ivs or the position of
ivs on the scatter we can see that you
have larger expression of those markers
bigger evs more markers associated to
them but if we go to this parallel
population here that shows up on day
three and disappear on day one there is
no expression of the marker so it means
that the origin of those cvs that they
are changing
in their scatter is clearly different
between the position on more red and
less violet
we could think that this is an artifact
that could be an issue with one of the
samples we repeat in different patients
and different days and we can see they
follow more or less the same pattern we
look at the statistics and these allow
us to identify
different biomarkers for different
patients
okay we can identify can we sort and
this is coming from john tx again um
this is uh srt and how the srt is able
to resolve these knees particles at
different points here and you can see
how small we can go with
this a nist nist beats so you can nicely
see from 80 and 90 we can nicely resolve
those populations what about evs in this
case these are background and what he
has done from the
sample is was trying to sort
those evs that there in this case they
are gfp values-like
particles
so he was sorting these particles and
with no no issues
and if you remember i was mentioning
about this no lies no wash
how does it look on the side of legs
practically the same it doesn't look the
same but if you see here these are my
erythrocytes
this is blue versus red and this one
here is red versus violet
when we look at the leukocytes they are
coming exactly in the same place that we
have them on their tune nxt
with the advantage that we can see also
with the red combination
let's go closer and we'll go now to the
playlist section and what we can see is
in this playlist section we have
different shapes of these platelets
which means that we might be ending up
with new superpolations of platelets we
don't know the next step is trying to
sort them out
and jordi patrice
just challenged me to try to identify if
these different kind of neutrophils they
could be also differentiated
by this different
scatters so i look at them focus into
those populations and try to see them
with more resource resolution into this
violence
you can see in this diagonal here that i
try a track here that these events are
always in a different position when we
use the multi-radial you can see that we
have a cloud of events floating around
the main populations
we can we have used the same concept in
this case for phytoplankton and we have
characterized different kind of
phetoplacton not just on the chlorophyll
and all the autofluorescence also using
the violet and red side scatter and what
we have seen in these different cultures
with more detail is that by using
violent red combination we can identify
multiple populations which is clearly
related to the different structures and
the different compositions and the
different ways that these structures
that we have on the plateau
so we help with the help of these
scatter characteristics and the
fluorescence we will be able to identify
with more precision to different super
populations
and during this workshop that we have
the symposium organized online
there was one time in here that i had to
do a practical session with evs my
samples were wrong and suddenly they
identify a bottle of nest of tea
over there i say okay they have bacteria
they have g's they have lots of things
let me see how these look like
in my flow spectrometer
so this is the setup that we have
this is the the t
a sample of the t
collected and analyzed using the violet
and red and i can see this population
here probably the bacteria
and something else here going outside of
scale
so uh i got one sample from cheese that
they were transfected the same ones i
mentioned before with transfection with
gfp and m cherry and here we can see the
gfps and the m cherry on the g's i tried
to localize them this is off the scale i
just need to drop down a little bit
again put them on the scale and see
where the g's are falling
and now i analyze again
the previous sample of t
and when we compare closely now
where is my
population of g's and i put the gate
around them
and i look at these ones here the g's
are falling here and this one's here
then they're bacteria
in a different angle with a different
relationship between the violet and the
red side is gathered when we look at
this with more detail we can see not
just that also a population right in the
middle
different than this other population
so what we will do next if we want to
identify as we have done with some
probably we just basically sort them put
them onto our plates grow them put them
on the pcr and identify who is you
first using those characteristics of the
scatter but don't forget about the
autofluorescence they also have
differences on the autofluorescence so
we'll use autofluorescence scatter sort
them and then characterize them with
proteomics genomics or whatever you want
we want to know more about them the
different kinds of ways to analyze evs
this is a series of webinars and john
ticks and i have created tunde uh
pandemia we were poor so we created six
uh five different videos also uh with
the support from pregnant culture and um
and all the support to do these
but with this i want to just thank a big
support i have received from bregman
culture uh during the last few years
also la plan at the institute of beckman
culture here in ireland
my colleagues and friends from san provi
uh british israel john ticks and
brandy uh some probably joanna and kasia
and the university of york karen and
peter they were fantastic and they
helped me a lot of course team personnel
in excite
and
bigger
acknowledge to all the users on the
facility that they they are accompanying
me during this process
and especially to
these two users javilanko and danny
blanco my wife and the core manager of
course you always need to acknowledge
the core facility manager
with this i'll stop my presentation and
open through any questions thank you
thank you dr blanco for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
is it possible to perform kinetics with
the cytoflex
well thank you thank you for the
question uh in fact this kinetic is one
of my favorite topics um that's when i
was working with the acrylic if you
remember i mentioned that we have
peristaltic pumps cytoflex are also the
very starting pumps and it allows us to
do a continuous kinetic means that
when you have a pressurized system you
have to stop make a gap and then you
cannot see the events for a while with
your
drugs or any kind of a stimulator you
want and just upload it and then you see
the kinetics in that process you can
lose a good amount of information that
is not there but because we have this
these uh peristaltic pumps we can
continuously analyze the sample how to
do it if you look at the cytoflex we can
just remove the lateral side that will
give us a bit more space and instead of
using the normal effects 5ml tubes you
use epidurals on those epinephrines you
can load from the lateral side your
stimuli your drugs meanwhile the sample
is running
and that means that we are speeding up
the time
to get your sample through the flow cell
and usually if you run it around medium
flow rate it will take around three four
seconds to start to see the cells when
they have been interacting with your
drug or your stimulant so cytoflex is a
really good platform to do any kind of
kinetics in real time
all right thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question go for
it
we have a cytoflex and we're using the
default settings that are coming with
the instrument is it good enough or do
you recommend going doing the gain
tracing
yeah so uh thank you for the question
again and this is um something that came
up in many many different training
courses and many of my users are asking
this is the default so no the default
that is coming from the site of like
it's telling you basically the
instrument is performing well and it
will give you the data good enough but
if you perform degeneration as i
mentioned in the talk you will see that
your signals will massively improve your
especially on the deemed side you will
be able to characterize better your weak
populations if you perform a gain
tradition it's a very very simple to say
you will perform in one day you save
this
new settings as your default settings
with your new default settings and once
you have it don't modify
you can optimize it later on for each
one of your experiments but that would
be a good starting point where you will
have maximum sensitivity on the
instrument
all right thank you dr blanco do you
have any final comments for our audience
yeah
i usually recommend the users to try the
instruments with their own samples
and this is what i would i will tell
them and if you have the chance to work
with the cytoflex you will be impressed
by two things the flexibility that you
have the sensitivity that you have and
how simple to use
the software it is
but at the same time how complex you
could do your analysis and this is what
i wanted to
show up during this presentation you can
do multiple things
in a very simple way and at the same
time in joining your analysis
thank you again dr blanco for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor beckman colter for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you